We need to hide that pattern, and the way to do that
is going to require encrypting the outputs in some way.
We have to encrypt them with different keys, though.
If we encrypted them all with the same key, then either the evaluator would be able to
determine all the outputs because the evaluator knows that key
or she couldn't determine any of them because she does not know that key.
We need to encrypt each output with different keys such that
when someone evaluates the truth table they can only decrypt the output
that corresponds to the row for the actual values they have.
The question is which of these values could be used for this entry in the truth table
to ensure that a circuit evaluator who knows a1 and b0 would be able to decrypt this output
and none of the other outputs.
Here are the choices. Be careful that more than one of these could be correct.